it's crazy
[Music]
so just heard about this place in
Philadelphia that sells pizza-flavored
ice creams the shop posted a photo on
Instagram of a scoop of the ice cream on
a slice of pizza
Instagram went crazy I figured I have to
check this out
Philadelphia's far and I don't have a
car
[Music]
and fili all right so we are just just
short of Philadelphia now
we're heading to little baby's ice cream
now where they have a Pizza flavored ice
cream that you can get on top a slice of
pizza
yeah the garlic it's the garlic scares
me that's that's an ingredient in ice
cream that I'm not quite sure I bet they
put some thought
[Music]
and so we're not exactly sure what we're
doing at the moment there we go
[Music]
we're about to try their Pizza flavored
ice cream so tomato paste ice cream
oregano garlic and just delicious nice
there's a pizza place that's literally
connected to babies ice cream so not
only are we gonna have some of their
Pizza flavored ice cream we're also
gonna have that ice cream on top yeah
besides pizza okay this is definitely
one of the stranger items that I've
eaten smells fantastic
yeah I mean world pizza
[Music]
I mean that that definitely do the pizza
oh my god it's crazy like that is
incredible how much it tastes like we
took it's so good I definitely wouldn't
want any sort of like sprinkles on this
sprinkle with red pepper flakes yeah red
pepper flakes I would not expect that to
screw the taste I love the hot the cold
together imagine they did like a pizza
waffle cone and put this ice cream in it
you good repeat it needs to be a little
messy it's you know a little bit of a
challenge to experience the good things
in life
I'm not chosen cheese
[Music]
this place has been serving this pizza
for a while just this week is when you
decide to blow up on Instagram then I
said this said six years this piece of
this slice is actually should be solidly
these big cookies pizza in the ice cream
it's also pretty good I don't think you
do any favors to either might be eaten
together so I want to point out that we
are terminated New Yorkers who left New
York for Philadelphia to eat pizza pizza
is quintessential to New York but Philly
has something else to offer
[Music]
I Philadelphia New York has a car
Justin this guy the only guy has a car
that's not why I asked you here though
yes it is yeah I understand why hasn't
it let's go